[Music]
so we're going to do this thing in two
different parts so first I'm going to
talk about you know what API
monetization is all about how do you go
about monetizing your api's we'll talk
about some framework pieces and then
mark will come and share a success story
and how they went from start to you know
in the journey of monetizing their API
so okay so this year you folks may have
noticed that we are doing Q a couple
different ways of course there there's a
mic out here up front so towards the end
we'll try and have some room for time
for Q&A but if you go to your next app
there's a there's a Dory Q&A link on it
you can also ask questions out there as
we go towards the end of the
presentation we'll be reading some of
the questions which are posted out there
okay with that let's get started so when
we talk about api's as companies try to
transform digitally what they're really
doing is they are converting and
expressing their capabilities in terms
of products and those products are
nothing but api's so clearly api is at
some level are a underlying technical
detail but they've been elevated in the
digital world to a business level
capability so in this picture out here
you can see various different enterprise
assets that many enterprises commonly
have and they build layers on top of it
and then API enable to be able to power
these powerful connected digital
experiences so what are some of these
experiences well for some it could be
building delightful apps that are used
by employees you could also be building
applications which are serving your
customer base or many cases these could
be api's which are powering full-on
ecosystems that you
partners so this session today we'll
touch a little bit about but how to
really unlock new business models how to
really grow that ecosystem and we'd also
hear first-hand from AccuWeather so in
our experience just like we have
different maturity levels for technology
stacks or certain technology aspects
there is a certain level of maturity
cycle with an API world as well
in many cases the need for customers
start with a simple project which is
just maybe a single API or maybe it's a
couple of api's pretty soon when that
starts to get a little more adoption it
becomes a little more mainstream and you
start to get into what we call as a
program which are much more than just
one or two api's and ultimately what you
really want to get to is an platform and
what that means is in a very systemic
way organically you are organized as an
API company when you think about being
API first at that level clearly you can
see at this scale the impact grows from
talking about things like developer
productivity innovation etc to be able
to generating new revenue models so API
is essentially now become these digital
channels where you're able to grow an
ecosystem and get into monetizing
certain Enterprise assets which you
weren't able to do before and that
becomes extremely important in this
digital transformation age where
companies are expressing their
capabilities as products which are
nothing but api's so let's take a peek
at you know why what's the motivation
behind trying to make sure that a API
program is successful well clearly there
is someone investing money in it there's
an investment new enterprise of the
corporation is making so it has to align
with business goals secondly you want to
be able to justify the return on
investment and last but not the least is
to have the right level of visibility
so one question which commonly comes up
when customers start embarking on an API
program well I have a slew of api's do I
just monetize everything turns out
that's not always a smart choice because
they have certain API they believe are
the right candidates for being monetized
but some aren't so let's talk about what
are some of the api's that shouldn't be
monetized right so some examples out
here are ticket booking or store
location these are organic core business
api's which provide value to your
consumers however they provide and drive
indirect value so let's say if your
Ticketmaster which also happens to be an
Apogee customer they have an application
where you can go and buy ticket for
various kinds of concerts right well
that's not something that they would
monetize because that's part of the core
business that they are offering however
you start getting into a section of your
api's which help developers and we're
talking about application developers
which help developers build revenue
generating apps so examples like weather
data messaging services and Mark out
here will talk about how they have
achieved that think about you building
an ecosystem there today
companies like AccuWeather are becoming
more of a data company that's their IP
and their many other application
developers who would like to Vivaan that
experience of taking weather data and
embedding them in different application
experiences that they're delivering to
the customers that's the perfect example
of how an API why that API should be
monetized so do we just take an ad hoc
approach or do we actually follow a
process so turns out there's a very
well-thought are interested what we call
as APM monetization framework it's
actually a very simple five-step process
so the first one starts with identifying
what are your core valuable assets that
provide some intrinsic business value
then understand who the audiences are
right who's really going to be consuming
those API those services and then comes
the main part how do you rely on them so
a package or a product bundle starts to
get into think little transformation
think api's are products so if you are
the product owner how do you really
bundle and create a package which is
good for regular consumers or direct
consumers on one end and maybe have a
different link mechanism for your
partners if you're trying to grow an
ecosystem and then offer which means
once you have a bundle how do you offer
up those api's to be consumed with
different kind of rate packages and rate
plans and then last but not the least
measure this is a very important part
because many times when I ask customers
hey how's the API program doing the API
performing well well great but that's
only part of the equation
are they deriving intrinsic value how do
you measure that or the API is being
adopted are they generating enough API
traffic from a set of partners that he
thought should be doing that right that
becomes a very important piece so what
does the Appaji provide from a
capability perspective so in this
picture I'll try and just go from the
right to the left to make it a little
more easy so this is what Apogee is API
monetization platform is is built on the
core platform with monetization
capabilities integrated into it so let's
start from the very right hand side on
the right hand side what you see are
nothing but business assets these are
the core enterprise data assets that we
spoke about in the very very first slide
they are exposed and modern api's at
some point or in some cases you may need
the platform to convert them into modern
REST API so once you do that API
monetization has two facets to it one
facet is you as the API provider so
that's one persona that we tackle so as
an API provider in this case AccuWeather
they are the provider of api's you have
a set of capability that you need such
as I need to bundle and create a package
around my api's I need to be able to
create read plans that I can associate
with that offering
and more importantly I want to be able
to do metering billing all those are
capabilities that an API provider needs
now you go to the other side of the
spectrum though the API are meant to
drive an ecosystem they're meant to
drive consumption across partners and
other constituents so for the API
consumer you equally need the ability
for them to be able to discover api's
for them to be able to subscribe to
certain great plants and do things of
that nature so all of that is transacted
for the developer portal and ultimately
those API that we spoke about are
powering these connected and detailed
experiences and the the developers on
this side becomes the key entity who are
the missing component in ensuring the
success of arabia program so with Apogee
the API platform which is a
full-featured full lifecycle API
platform with API monetization built
into it it is an extremely comprehensive
flexible and extensible platform so we
have a lot of capabilities in terms of
the different kind of fees rate card
options freemium plans you are able to
leverage many of the capabilities
built-in and I'll show a very quick demo
and use them to be able to quickly
monetize your api's okay with that I'm
going to do a very quick demo here I'm
hoping the demo gods are with us today
how many people out here just a quick
show of hands have used Apogee edge okay
another question real quick from the W
last question give me how many are
monetizing their api's today even if
you're not doing that to the apogee
platform okay excellent so in this quick
demo I'm going to cover a few different
aspects of the core platform and then
I'll also talk about the the
monetization pieces as well so here
I'm logged into a PG edge this is our
management UI and so I'm logged in think
about me as an API provider at this
point so I'm using this UI to
essentially build what we call as API
proxies so think about the slide that I
just showed really have a lot of
enterprise assets ok though this is
nothing but API that you have either you
own them organically or they are sitting
on top of some packaged applications
that you have or perhaps some homegrown
systems think about Apogee sitting in
the front as a facade layer so when we
represent those API is we do them well
by what we call it api proxies an api
proxy is nothing but just a simple
method definition of flow which says
here's an API call which comes in
execute some policies and it goes to a
specific back-end which is nothing but
your API so API proxy happens to be the
number one primary construct in the a
page platform now what happens is when
you as the product owner in this case
who owns the portfolio of api's you come
into this screen out here which is what
we call as a product bundle so within
the notion of app yet you have this
concept of a product think about a
product as being nothing but a grouping
of a certain number of API so let's say
you have hundred api's and you may only
decide to monetize five of them remember
we spoke about which api is we monetize
in which we don't so if you think about
that bundle you get coming out here take
that product bundle in this case we just
call it add service prod bundle and this
may have four or five API that you want
to monetize so in this product bundle
definition you define what your
transaction recording policy is so it's
pretty simple
anytime you want to monetize your api's
you want to be able to ensure that
you're only monetizing those API calls
where you have a successful response you
may have certain errors with API proxies
out here in this definition you're
saying which API
do I really want to be able to recognize
for monetization purposes so in effect
this kind of becomes your system of
record for keeping track of which api
having monetized so that's the kind of
stuff you declare out here out here you
define which specific resources within
those API you want to be able to
monetize and you can add specific custom
attributes all of this level of detail
is available to the metering and billing
engine as API traffic is being piped
through the API platform it is picking
up what you define out here in terms of
enforcing some of those aspects
once you're done building a product
bundle what you then end up doing is
building a rate plan and this is really
there you have the ability to create
different kinds of rate plans so we
spoke about some of them so essentially
you have a provider will figure out what
kind of offering you wanna make for
these set of api's or this API product
you give it a rate plan name you pick
the bundle and you pick the rate plan
type so this is an example of what I was
talking about now you can monitor the
APS differently you can say well you're
going to pay a flat fee for a monthly
use I don't really care about volume
it's X number of dollars a month you can
pick fees only or you can have a rate
card which will say his rate car which
says how many api's and for what amount
you can also do something much more
sophisticated where if you have a
partner ecosystem which is getting
traffic onto your platform you can use a
revenue share arrangement where you know
there's a cut of a specific amount of
revenue dollar amount that you as an
enterprise can ascertain from that
transaction so again these are various
options out here I'm not going to spend
time on each one of them and then you
can create the start and the end date so
as an API provider you take on the api's
you created a bundle and you associate
that to a specific rate plan once that's
done the monetization engine kicks in as
API traffic starts to flow we start
recording based on your preferences
those api's which are meant for
recording purposes
and they're very quickly just how our or
some of the reporting capability as a
provider that's available so you can go
create different kinds of reports out
here revenue report billing prepaid
balance so again from a monetization
perspective we have integration into
payment providers but many customers of
ours who already have pre-built and
homegrown billing systems we can add to
the system of record and provide you all
the transactions that you need to be
able to Bill your customers so I'll show
you an example of a report out here real
quick but mark is going to cover that in
some more detail it's out here here's an
example of a detailed report which can
come in and it will give you the
transaction output so see if I have any
data in here okay so here's a very quick
example of some transactions out here
and some recording being done around
certain kind of transactions now again
this data can be taken and done in to
your billing system or as I mentioned we
can use other capabilities from here to
be able to generate billing and
reporting as well so with that let's go
back to the slides at this point I'm
going to turn it over to mark and then
he will walk us through the Accu of the
story and how they took off the program
and also talked about the consumer side
of the house and how they tackle certain
things like product bundles and rate
plans with that mark take it away thank
you very much and first we're gonna
watch a short video
[Music]
I became fascinated with the weather
when I was three years old when I fell
in love with snow and by the time I was
seven I knew I wanted to be a weather
forecaster
so AccuWeather I started in college as a
second year graduate student and
AccuWeather is now the largest source of
weather forecasts and warnings in the
world we've achieved this by having the
greatest accuracy saccular was founded
56 years ago really on pen and paper
serving business customers over the last
10 to 15 years really morph into a
digital solution and API is basically
powered that entire transformation the
API is a way of feeding the best weather
information into other apps and
integrating easily however they want to
use it we've been using aperture for our
API developer portal for over eighteen
months and since day one when wheeler
leased arted with zero developers we've
now branched out to over 50,000
developers out there in the community a
lot of people don't realize how many
products and services are out there in
the marketplace using a cube other API
is to power that back-end we serve
nearly 50 billion API requests per day
Appaji made it very simple for us to set
up self signup for potential clients it
gives us the ability to monetize our API
and also to offer free api's to people
so they can try it out by having access
to analytics we're able to really get
real-time information for what our
developers are doing what they like what
they don't like allows us to make that
quick judgment to what we want to do
moving forward in the future as well as
helping our developers get better
experiences out of our API so the
weather forecast is more important than
it's ever been the weather can cost a
flight to be cancelled rain out a
baseball game it interacts with
everything there millions of developers
and potential users around the world for
the xapi eye they can take our data and
our forecasts integrate it into whatever
they're doing and make it better
[Music]
all right well first want to say thank
you very much for coming out today and
thank you for two appletinis for
allowing me the opportunity to be here
so as you saw we're actually coming up
on our 57 years hit AccuWeather and
really was company was founded on the
principle that joel understood the value
of specialized forecast for people and
what i mean by this is he started going
to local businesses in the area and
selling like to gas companies
specialized forecast help them predict
their energy yields or to a local ski
resort in helping them predict when they
should be making snow overnight to be
the most efficient and save money over
time doing this and kind of selling
these specialized forecasts he earned
that reputation for his value in the
service of what he was doing and the
company evolved into newspaper radio TV
and eventually websites but as you heard
our CTO Chris paddie say in the past 10
to 15 years we've really become a full
digital solution and that evolution
happened because of api's but what makes
weather data so important well the fact
is is that the weather impacts
everything what you do what you where
where you go every day you make
conscious and unconscious decisions
based on the weather whether you realize
it or not that's why so many products
out there in the market are using
weather and incorporating the weather to
enhance that product experience some
products are built specifically around
the weather some popular examples is
you've seen phones tablets watches a lot
of products out there that give that
information but there's a lot of
products that have actionable and
triggered automated decision-making
responses like connected home products
smart thermostats smart cars watches
there's also been smart health products
one of my favorite ones that I like to
tell a brief story just to understand
use cases of weather API is in the real
world is a company called cojiro health
cojiro health has a brand of connected
inhalers and they use our API is in a
way that if for somebody or for
respiratory illness and they use their
inhaler it calls our current conditions
API over time
as you began to use it it be guilted
begins to build a database of that
current conditions information
it applies machine learning to it tries
to find patterns identifies potential
weather-related triggers that are
causing that respiratory problem and it
then uses it to look at our forecast API
to try to predict when you may have
another asthma attack so I just always
thought it was a really cool
outside-the-box use case of our API s
and it just shows how powerful can be to
enhance your products further using
weather data but cojiro is just one of
many enterprise clients that AccuWeather
works with we've been actually selling
api's for over 10 years at AccuWeather
not to mention that AccuWeather runs a
lot of our own products and services on
our own api's so cojiro it and all these
other companies up here help make up our
50 billion api requests per day that we
talked about in the villi video I mean
I'm willing to bet actually that pretty
much everybody in this room has at least
one product in their home that is
powered by AccuWeather api's on the
backend that's how popular they are but
the thing is in doing all this
enterprise partnerships that we had we
began to realize we think we could do
more we started to think we're we
missing an opportunity with what we were
doing by focusing on these large
companies these are the biggest names in
industry but the industry is
consistently growing and evolving so we
wanted to make sure we're looking at
what is the next great idea who's
potentially the next big partnership
that we can work with so to get there we
created developer back um so in May of
2017 we partnered with Apogee officially
to create this portal and the purpose of
it is it's a self-serve portal to engage
the developer community in a new way we
wanted it to be easy to use and help us
increase our business and revenue
opportunities without having to
significantly increase our resources to
get there so how did we get along this
journey to actually create this site I'm
actually gonna go back to profiles
monetization framework and go through
this so the five key points identify
understand package offer measure
to create the portal we went through
this exercise carnival on her own I mean
we had the recipe for an enterprise
success but it was a very custom and
time-consuming product process to kind
of get to that point of selling it to
those customers so we wanted we started
asking ourselves how can we translate
this to a self-serve environment how can
we make this a cleaner more efficient
process again not trying to hire all new
resources to get all the eventual
clients we wanted to have something else
simpler and easy to use let them find us
come to us so the first step is identify
for us what sets us apart what would
people want act or weather or why do
people want AccuWeather api's for their
own products as you heard Joel Myers
have founders say in the video I mean
our accuracy is important to us we've
been ranked number one for the past
three years in a third-party study for
our accuracy we have a very truly global
service we have like over two languages
and dialects 60 countries for severe
weather alerts I mean literally
everywhere on the planet we provide the
weather for we also have a very robust
and efficient API and that's very
important to us again 50 billion API
requests per day at times we serve over
1.5 million API requests per second for
some companies that's more than they do
in a day some more than a week or even a
month we're doing that at times during
the day in a second so we had the
confidence in our data as a product and
we felt it was definitely unique to be
able to offer to our end users because
we feel an API could be more valuable
for your audience if it has impactful
data and also had s have an API service
they can trust rely on so we felt we had
these with our enterprise api's so next
we had to think about who's our new
target target audience so again the
weather impacts everything and
everything is powered by api's so we
wanted people to use AccuWeather api's
to power their ideas and business but
not just the big companies we wanted to
work with the startups the small
businesses the single developers the
students the weather enthusiasts was
just a great idea but the problem was
again our sales resources were very
focused on you
enterprise agreements into space and the
contracts were very custom and it was a
very custom for the content and the
pricing and it can sometimes take days
or weeks so we knew we needed something
that was again self-serve quick
something that would increase the
opportunity without increasing those
resources so we started thinking how can
we engage people on their own and get
them to come to a cue other on their own
without having a sales staff
consistently going after them so that
Aletta store packages and this is
probably the most interesting aspect
I'll start with saying we love AB G's
monetization features because of the
options that we had we actually utilize
I know it's a little blurry on this
screen but we actually utilize a base
fee and a monthly CPM rate we also offer
a free package which we didn't offer
before which that alone is great because
now people can come to us find us test
us on their own but the base fee gives
us the ability to kind of set a a soap
so to speak threshold for API request
limit and that base fee covers up to
that point but instead of capping and
cutting off a developer as you're using
the API we then have a CPM rate if you
go over that threshold and we'd love
that because it gave the developers more
freedom and flexibility to do what they
wanted there is no hard cap on our
package limit we didn't want to stifle
to developers creativity the last thing
you want to do as a developer is worry
about oh great my products taking off
I hope my package doesn't cut me off
before the end of the month so having
that ability to let them go over it's
great it lets them to focus on growing
their idea not worrying about minor
things but as we went in through this we
started looking think about what content
do we expose for AccuWeather we had our
enterprise api's we intentionally did
not offer everything from our enterprise
api's on this portal because the portal
does a lot more for that for us than
just simply automate our a new audience
experience for us or a new audit target
audience
it helps us act as a sales channel to
lead developers to our AccuWeather api
and eventually hopefully to our sales
team for a greater partnership
opportunity so each package has
additional content as you increased in
dollar amount but some content is still
by
contacting our sales team only it's a
more premium content more premium
experience and we want to be able to
talk to those different partnership
opportunities to see how can we help you
again part of my role how can we help
you how can we work with you really
leverage that API we weren't getting rid
of our enterprise sales process we just
wanted to supplement it make it stronger
another thing we had to think about was
our own lines of business everything
internally had AccuWeather for the most
part runs on our own api's we also have
a lot of other data delivery methods so
we had to make sure we're being
consistent and fair across the board
with our data and pricing we can't be
cutting out our own lines of business by
offering a package with set prices but
still not offer other opportunities
elsewhere so we had to be cognizant of
the fact that we're looking at all the
ways that AccuWeather brings data to the
people and making sure that I was fair
and consistent across the board and then
finally last thing we had to be mindful
of is what our competition was doing has
any good business would say you have to
always be mindful of your competition
making sure that we're still
consistently providing that accurate
weather data forecasts and a reliable
API service we want people to come to
AccuWeather because of the name and the
brand that they know but we want them to
also stay you have to maintain that
consistency so now that we had our
packages we had to think about how put
it out there so by partnering with
Apogee it helps solved another challenge
that we had to docq other and that was
making our api's easy to find and use
people were unsure before how to get to
our API it's before the most common way
was that people were seeing some of the
partnerships that we had and potentially
had a product in their home or under
their phone or something a widget and
they saw the AccuWeather brand label on
there
and they thought okay there's data here
somehow how do I get it
they tried to call our sales team and
get started from there but then that's
another challenge there's a lot of
people that don't want to talk to a
sales team member
think about if you're a startup company
or a single developer or better yet a
student do you really want to talk to a
sales rep and go through a contract and
a legal process no you want to just go
somewhere sign up and get started so by
having this portal it made it much
easier for us to get the word out there
let
people find it try it under own sign up
for free get to some testing you want
them to just sign up pay and go no delay
no days waiting minutes now get started
but once it was available we had to
create a new marketing campaign to try
to get the word out there and
reintroduce ourselves to the community
again people weren't sure how to find us
before but now we're out there we had
this portal so we want to let people
know about it the partnership with
Apogee has been great for us because I
mean as you saw that commercial that was
just though one of a three-part series
actually we've also been on many blogs
and opportunities with them it's all
we've also leveraged other Google
resources at Google Adwords and digital
campaigns and as you see from all this
cool swag pictures we've taken it to
hackathons to kind of get the word out
there and it's been really cool taking
it to hackathons and letting the
students know or other developers if
they want to keep using this after the
hackathon just stay on the site sign up
and go so it's bringing that awareness
and the engagement in that way too but
another thing we had to do is make sure
we had a proper presence on developer
sites and resources like even
programmable go programmable web excuse
me our presence was confirmed and
studies like this one from late 2017 and
I showed us grass specifically because
we launched in about mid or mid 2017 so
this was just after the launch for
portal and this represents the api's and
SDKs the readers from their site were
most interested in and as you can see
users had a very strong interest in
AccuWeather
but if you actually drill down into our
profile and read some of the comments
people still didn't know how to get to
us we even saw people saying oh you have
to go through a sales channel it's very
difficult never mind
since then now at the portal we've
refreshed our presence so to speak we've
gone to these different resources and
said we have this new portal we've
actually seen a lot of people come
through sites like programmable web
found us and then moved on and actually
purchase content so it's making sure you
have that proper presence and reputation
for your product as you get out there so
now that we felt we had a solid new
sales channel at the portal and a solid
reputation it was important for us to
nurture our product and that you have
two consistent
keep measuring so we do use app G edge
and these numbers are actually I stole
the or pulled these out on Thursday of
last week I was finalizing this
presentation so as you see since May of
2017
that's our numbers and with Apogee edge
we're able to consistently monitor
growth like this we can get snapshots of
our users in real time it allows us to
quickly see any changes we make to our
documentation or marketing campaigns
that we potentially use to help get the
word and awareness out there are they
being successful so it's been very
helpful for us to kind of get that
bird's-eye view of those numbers and
growth and success but also with edge we
can drill down and get the individual
analytics for individual accounts so
with this we can see what ap eyes are
using what ap eyes are they not using
are they doing something well are there
any problems because that happens to
order any abusers of our API but also
more importantly for product managers
and the sales team or there any new
opportunities we can look at clients
like this and see what ap eyes are using
order using excessively and we can see
is there a potential here to reach out
to them as a new client because again we
wanted this portal to be a sales channel
not just something to replace but
something to actually help bring us the
most promising leads let them come on
our own hopefully even with a small
single idea and continue to grow it with
us and hopefully be the next big
partnership so it's really created us
for us a great new lead generator as
well as well as just providing
additional revenue line of revenue for
us and finally you have to monitor your
overall health so with this we can look
at our response times the the volume the
airs you have to consistently where we
can consistently monitor our overall
health in the API and make sure we're
providing that fast reliable service
that we've been come to known for but
because if you can't provide that good
reliable service why would anyone even
put you under product to begin with the
last thing you want to worry about as a
developer is oh no my data provider just
failed for no reason no you want to
focus on nurturing your idea in your
product you want to be able to grow but
thankfully developers have been you
and since our launch we've already see
some pretty inspiring stories so we
actually had the young man come to us
and he asked if he could use our api's
to power his tortoise habitat and what
it is he said his family had asked for
two sabot and they used our current
conditions API to actually help control
and automatically trigger in the
ecosystem within that habitat based on
the outside conditions so it's
automatically adapting using our current
conditions API we also had another
gentleman come to us and say I have a
backyard awning and I'm using your API
to automatically power it to open and
close based on little sky conditions and
precipitation and then he even reached
out to us and said your API is so easy
to use and we loved the accuracy and
they were both actually just using the
free trial so just again a weather
enthusiasts or somebody of a great idea
how easy it was for them to go through
and then finally in hackathons this is
actually a picture from last fall when
we were at Penn State University and
what was great and to hear for us is as
we take this portal their students were
coming up to us and saying excuse me
with a little to no experience working
with api's they were able to go on our
portal because the documentation was
clean easy to use using the portal that
we had with Apogee they were able to
just go in there and start developing
they didn't have to worry about how does
this work and how do I do this they were
just able to flex their creativity and
just start building some really great
ideas so there's all this success though
we still see even greater potential for
ourselves we know there's even room we
can improve adding more content of new
more pricing options so we're excited
about what we can do with apogee to
enhance this and monetize it even
further so overall we've been we just
love the partnership that we've been
having with Apogee and what it's done
for a developer community the pair of a
paraphrase Joel Meyers developers are
able to take our api's make their
products better because for us that has
always been the whole goal let
developers easily put the power of
AccuWeather
behind our products and build cool
things
[Music]